[Música]
ah
miles de médicos así como trabajadores
de diversas áreas del sistema sanitario
peruano para realizar un su labores por
48 horas en todo el país para exigir
reformas en el sector salud un mayor
presupuesto mejores condiciones
laborales y de bioseguridad con la que
diariamente encaran la pandemia del cobi
19 los profesionales denuncian que la
emergencia sanitaria ha permitido
mostrar la crítica situación en la que
trabajan hospitales en los que faltan
camas respiradores artificiales oxígeno
medicinas entre otros los servidores de
salud anunciaron que evalúan endurecer
sus protestas e iniciar una huelga de
hambre si el gobierno del presidente de
martín vizcarra no atiende sus reclamos
por su parte al ministerio de salud
señaló que se ha distribuido equipos de
protección personal en todo el perú y se
pagaron bonos de riesgo de trabajo
conocidos como los bonos kobe hasta el
mes de mayo y que la escala salarial aún
se mantiene evaluación este conflicto se
produce cuando perú con más de 28 mil
decesos según algunos especialistas
acaba de convertirse en el país con la
mayor tasa de mortalidad del mundo por
el coronavirus
[Música]
la demanda de equipos de protección
adecuados y suficientes para enfrentar
la pandemia fue una de las razones que
llevó a las calles a protestar en días
recientes a miembros del personal de
salud en panamá y es que más de 3000
personas que prestan servicios en este
sector se han contagiado del virus había
además un retraso de pago de salarios en
una parte de estos trabajadores que ya
había sido resuelta por parte del
ejecutivo pero ahora se abre un compás
de espera mientras se concreta la
dotación de las herramientas de trabajo
por ejemplo nos comentaba una enfermera
que deben alargar el tiempo de vida útil
de las mascarillas que se le entregan un
tipo de implemento no le dan otro y que
además dudan de la calidad de muchos de
estos equipos mientras el país transita
ahora un proceso de reapertura gradual
la expectativa de este personal es
totalmente distinta al resto de la
población porque el mismo trabajo de
vigilancia que se ha intensificado
durante cinco meses no cambiará
[Música]
corea del sur ha encargado esta semana
una huelga de médicos en pleno repunte
de casos de kobe 19 el paro ha estado
encabezado por médicos residentes y en
prácticas en protesta por los planes del
gobierno de incrementar las plazas en
las escuelas de medicina y por tanto de
incrementar el precio de las
matriculaciones se calcula que casi un
70% de estos médicos en fase formativa
han secundado este paro de tres días
esta pasada semana a raíz de la huelga y
del aumento de casos de kobe del
gobierno ha prometido que va a congelar
sus planes sin embargo residentes e
internistas han insistido en que van a
realizar más huelgas en semanas
sucesivas hasta que este plan de reforma
no quede absolutamente descartado en los
paros de esta semana han afectado
algunas consultas algunas cirugías no
esenciales algunas de las cuales han
tenido que ser canceladas pero en todo
caso no ha afectado de momento el
sistema de prevención o de atención para
pacientes con kobe 19 de hecho en ese
sentido hay ahora mismo preocupación
sobre una posible escasez de camas
hospitalarias para pacientes con
coronavirus en la región de seúl que es
ahora mismo la más afectada por el
aumento de casos
[Música]